hi Matt here a big thank you to all of
our listeners who've taken a few moments
to vote for us for the Webby listener
Choice Awards
there's still some time left and we
invite all of you to vote at stanford.io
slash Webby w-e-b-b-y
thank you for your support and for
listening turning habits into choices is
a big motivator for the teaching and
communication coaching that I do but
before you can make choices from your
habits you first have to form habits
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast
[Music]
today I am really looking forward to
speaking with DJ Fogg BJ is a research
associate and Adjunct professor at
Stanford University he is the founder
and director of the Stanford behavioral
Design Lab BJ also coaches companies and
Executives around the world finally he
is the author of two great books
persuasive technology and tiny habits
welcome BJ thank you for inviting me
I've been looking forward to talking to
you me too so let's go ahead and get
started as many of our listeners know I
have long been fascinated by persuasion
and behavioral change one of the things
that first drew me to your work BJ was
that you refer to something called the
information action fallacy and I believe
it's this fallacy that helped you create
your model of behavior change can you
share with us what this fallacy is and
then share the three components of your
behavior change model for decades maybe
longer people have assumed that if you
just give people information it will
change the their behavior and this
doesn't work very well and so I decided
to give this problem a name this
fallacia name and that's what it's
called the information action fallacy
and it goes like this if we give people
information that will then change their
attitude
and then with Attitude Change they will
then change their behavior
now those links between information and
attitude changes that's not a very
reliable link and even if you can change
somebody's attitude that doesn't
necessarily change their behavior the
second part of your question had to do
with the behavior model so this came
together for me in about 2007 and it is
a model that describes all Behavior
types in all cultures and so on it's a
universal model it goes like this a
behavior
happens when three things come together
at the same moment one there's
motivation to do that behavior
two there's ability to behavior and
three there's a prompt something that
says to this Behavior now and when all
those things come together the behavior
happens
and if one any one of those things is
missing like there's no motivation or
there's no ability or no prompt then the
behavior does not happen as the father
of two teenage boys I have certainly
seen the information action fallacy
happen in my own life give them lots of
information hoping it'll change
attitudes and we don't see any Behavior
changed in terms of the model the
question I have is around what is a
prompt how do you define that prompt I
get ability I get motivation what what
does a prompt refer to and that's an
excellent question Matt because I mean
the idea of ability and motivation being
important has been around for a long
time you can talk about skill and will
and so on which is effectively that the
Breakthrough really was understanding
there has to be a prompt a prompt is
anything that says do this now your
phone ringing is a prompt somebody
asking you a question is a prompt to
reply you looking at an action item on
your to-do list is a prompt there are a
whole bunch of ways that when we
couldn't even be prompted internally
like sensing hunger is a prompt and
what's important about that is you've
got to make sure for the behaviors we
want that the prompts happen and if
we're trying to stop for reduced
behaviors to minimize or get rid of the
prompts so you can design for Behavior
change simply in some ways by focusing
on prompt design I see so it's finding
the prompts that can trigger the
behavior you want or removing some of
those prompts to to get rid of the
behaviors you don't want to invoke yeah
so that's one of the three things lovers
one of the three things you have to play
around with to get a behavior happen or
not to happen and even though it's you
can write it in three letters b equals m
a p it is a I think a profound model
that can be used in so many ways can you
give us an example of a way in your
coaching or teaching that can relate to
to the listeners and the things that
they a behavior they might want to
change and how they can use those three
levers to accomplish that yeah let's say
that you want to read more I mean we
read all the time like email and social
media but you want to read books so
number one Define what the behavior is
okay I want to read this particular book
okay reading more is abstract it's not a
behavior it's like an outcome so pick a
book you actually want to read so that's
the motivation part don't pick a book
you don't want to read
so that's motivation next ability how do
you make it easier to read that book
well you could get a paper version of
the book and you could set it right by a
chair that you sit in all the time and
then the third thing prompt what is
going to prompt to remind me in this
case the Kindle sitting there that is
its prompt right there I don't have to
put on a to-do list I don't have to put
on the calendar I don't put up a Post-It
note in this case the object that I need
to read the Kindle or maybe the the
paperback version of a book is the thing
that will prompt me so when you sit down
you see the book it's like oh I can read
now and just open up the book and
continue Reading part of what you said
that was really enlightening for me was
that notion of being very specific about
the behavior you you want to change so
it's not just reading in general and and
I said often lofty goals for myself I
want to do more exercise or lose weight
but it sounds like what I should be
doing is being much more specific and
and that's I think going to be really
helpful unlike my work on behavioral
change which is focused on how to change
other people's attitudes and behaviors
you focus on how we can change our own
behavior the unit of change you
highlight is habits can you define what
a habit is and share some of the maxims
that you've come up with regarding
habits yeah so the way I Define habit
it's a behavior you do quite
automatically with without deciding
without deliberating without thinking
very much and we have many many habits
and the good news here is habits are
easier to form than most people think if
you do it in the right way and that's
what my tiny habits method is all about
it just breaks it down it's very
straightforward and people can form
habits quickly and easily looking at
creating habits or any type of lasting
change I've distilled the keys to Habit
formation or engagement or lasting
change down into two statements number
one is help yourself do to what you
already want to do so notice in that so
you pick habits you already want to do
don't pick habits you don't want to do
and help yourself to it and you help
yourself do it by making that habit
easier and there's different ways to
make it easier so we're back to Ability
we're back to Simplicity and you make it
help yourself do that by making sure
there's a prompt So within that one
statement that I call fog Maxim number
one help yourself do what you already
want to do it brings together motivation
ability and prompt in that statement so
that's number one fog Maxim number two
is help yourself feel successful and
even though that's four words that can
be challenging to do but it is very much
worth knowing how to help and learning
and developing the skill frankly it's
the skill of helping yourself feel
successful because it's that feeling
it's that emotion of success that wires
and habits that's what causes a behavior
that you're deliberating or deciding or
thinking about turn into a behavior you
do without thinking or deciding Behavior
you do quite automatically it's emotions
that create habits and that's why the
feeling of success is so important
because when you do a new behavior and
you feel successful then you shift it on
this Continuum automaticity and it
becomes more automatic I think most of
us think of habits as a mental effort so
the the role of emotion to me is really
really intriguing and setting us up for
Success so we can have that feeling of
success as a reinforcing mechanism I
think is really really cool you said the
exact right word you it by causing
yourself to feel successful you are
self-reinforcing and you can do this
deliberately you don't have to leave
that reinforcement chance or to other
people you can self-reinforce and that's
part of the tiny habits method and we
call that a pro approach celebration but
what you're doing is causing yourself to
feel successful at the right moment in
order to self-reinforce and cause that
behavior to become more likely and more
automatic that's great and and I've got
lots of of ways to to feel really good
about some of the habits I'm trying to
to take on I I'm going to reward myself
with my favorite chocolate I think I'd
love for you to give me specific advice
on a habit I'm trying to develop better
as many of our listeners know I'm a big
believer in paraphrasing as a way to
validate others comments and to validate
the accuracy of my understanding what
advice can you give me to make
paraphrasing a stronger better habit for
me so in other words what you want to
hear from me is how to make paraphrasing
a stronger habit touche touche yes you
you already have this habit clearly
okay you know
um first of all get clear I mean you're
pretty clear on of course you're super
clear on this map but people listening
it's like okay what is paraphrasing mean
and then when somebody says something to
you have that be the prompt or the
reminder
to paraphrase it back to them and then
when you do that and this is where the
reinforcement comes in pay attention to
how they respond and I think many times
you will see if you're talking face to
face you will see them light up or you
will it will say yes exactly Embrace
that as a positive result in other words
pay attention to their response that
will reinforce the paraphrasing Behavior
so let me paraphrase that of myself
again number one be clear on what it
means to paraphrase number two know when
you're going to do it what is the prompt
or cue it's after somebody tells you
something and then after you paraphrase
stay tuned for that reaction from the
other person and really allow yourself
to feel that positive reaction that will
help create that habit that's really
helpful and the last piece I find most
helpful is I am often so focused on just
making sure I paraphrase that I don't
take the time to actually celebrate the
result of that paraphrasing like wow
that person really responded positively
or they gave me more information as a
response to my paraphrasing so that
celebration piece which which clearly I
can see would be reinforcing in in sent
me and motivate me to to paraphrase even
more would be really helpful so have
that Clarity of what I mean by
paraphrasing and to me it's really
distilling down what the person is
saying use their response as my trigger
to actually initiate the paraphrase and
then the big one for me is celebrate did
I did I paraphrase that okay BJ how'd I
do I thought that was great I'd like to
change the subject a little bit to
better understand from you what role
specificity and repetition play in
building a new habit you often hear just
keep doing it over and over again and it
becomes a habit and I'm not quite sure
you believe that yeah exactly well
specificity be very clear going back to
the reading example don't you think I
want to read more be very clear I want
to read this book and you might even
Define how much of the book I think
that's less important than knowing what
book and you might even Define the
location I want to read this book while
sitting in this chair it seems that
there's a big difference to our brains
between read more and after I sit in the
chair I will read this book and our
brain can connect with the second and
prompt you to do it and you're more
likely to do it the next topic around
repetition that's long been said that
repetition is the key to creating habits
and that's just not true it's emotions
what role does repetition play well if
you do a behavior and you feel strong
positive emotion as you do it that habit
will wire in very quickly there's a type
of habit that I call one and done you do
it one time and and the Habit is wired
in because the emotion was so strong for
example you buy a new car and you drive
the car to work that's not going to take
very long for driving the new car to
become a habit because you're going to
feel so great or you find a new way to
drive to Stanford that's prettier and
faster the sense of success of it's more
beautiful and faster is going to wired
it if the feeling of success is not that
strong then it takes more it's like
you're inching toward the automaticity
and so in that case doing the Habit
let's say daily allowing yourself to
feel successful then that will create a
solid habit it won't be one and done so
you need to if you can't feel a strong
positive emotion you need to repeat the
habit
but it's not the repetition that's
creating the Habit it's the emotion that
you feel so let's be really clear about
that yes you may need to repeat the
habit and cause yourself to feel
successful multiple times for it to
really wire in but it's it's not a
function of repetition it's a function
of emotion
aha so let me give you an example if I I
know exercise is good for me but I don't
like exercising or it hurts and I'm
tired and fatigued afterwards forcing
myself to to continue to exercise
actually is working against building it
as a habit is what I heard you say
because I'm not having a positive
experience it would be better for me to
find a more positive way to get that
physical activity is that correct yes
exactly so there's at least 100 ways to
exercise find the way that you like find
the way that causes you to feel
successful and just because somebody
runs a lot doesn't mean running is the
right exercise for you I know it's not
the right one for me that's for sure it
would be very hard for me to create
running as a habit even though I'm
really great at habits and part of being
great at creating habits is knowing
which habits to pick so don't pick the
ones that you don't like or don't want
or are painful for you I got it I
actually do enjoy running and in fact
the the reward and celebration I have is
I get the opportunity to listen to
podcasts so for me that's positive but
there are many other types of exercise I
do not like and I like what you just
shared that can help me look for others
that would be more positive so before we
end I like to ask the same three
questions of all of my guests are you
willing to answer them for me sure let's
go okay if you were to capture the best
communication advice you have ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would
those five to seven words be
remember what it's like not to know
oh
so cool why is that the advice you would
share I was mentored by a brilliant man
named Jonas Harris and this is back in
the day when I was a technical writer
and he was teaching me to be a technical
editor and to teach technical writing
and one of his big things was remember
what it's like not to know and
essentially that's a way to say have
empathy you know and consider the
audience and remember where they're
coming from and that is guided my work
ever since you know I moved away from
technical writing and Technical
communication and other things but
remember what it's like not to know yeah
that is such powerful advice because
quite frankly it's the antidote to the
curse of knowledge we all know a lot
about what we're communicating and we
miss helping people understand it
because we come from the wrong place so
that beginner's mind I I really
appreciate I'll be curious to hear your
answer to question two who is a
communicator that you admire and why
there is a songwriter named Sean Edwards
and I've been working with her on songs
about habits for kids so I've been
working with her for about a year a year
and a half and she is amazing at taking
Concepts like I'll write some draft
lyrics and they're just too complicated
and not good for kids and she'll just
crunch them down into a much simpler
version that still has the power and
then she can put music to him it is just
amazing to see how she communicates with
words and music for the audience we're
trying to reach which is kids from 3 to
11. I think it's great that you're
trying to help kids in that age group
and I think it's fascinating to know
that you're a Lyricist I did not know
that that was one of the many things
that you have I I see myself more as the
Court Jester
working with someone as talented as
Shauna Edwards what a privilege and I've
just learned so much but mostly just
admire what she can do that I probably
never will be able to do it is it is a
true pleasure to be in the presence of
of people who have mastered their craft
for sure
final question question three what are
the first three ingredients that go into
a successful communication recipe I
wrote down these words before we started
but it's a great kind of wrap-up of what
we talked about empathy number one
simplicity
and practicality
certainly certainly and those
ingredients can absolutely help you be
very clear concise and in many ways
compelling and I appreciate that and and
I appreciate that your answer to this
question was a model of all three of
those well thank you BJ I love your
actionable specific advice and guidance
I encourage everybody to check out the
work you do especially the tiny habits
book you have a free five-day course I I
am a graduate of that course I have
found it very helpful thank you for your
time and thank you for your Insight
thank you Matt it's been a pleasure to
talk to you
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Ryan Campos and me Matt
Abrahams our music was provided by Floyd
Wonder for more information and episodes
find us on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcasts thank you and please make
sure to subscribe and follow us on
LinkedIn
foreign